I was going to come in today and tell you
that a Democrat has a chance to defeat a Republican
in the state of Montana.
But if I told you that, it wouldn't be accurate,
because it's not that a Democrat has a chance
to defeat a Republican in Montana.
The truth is that a Democrat is leading by
seven against a Republican in Montana.
This is a really, really big deal.
We'll talk about Montana, then we'll apply
it a little bit broadly in 2016.
Donald Trump won Montana 56 to 36 over Hillary
Clinton 20 point win in that state.
In 2014, Republican Steve Daines won his Senate
race over Amanda Curtis, also by a big margin
by 18, 58 to 40.
But incumbent Republican Senator Steve Daines,
who won in 2014, is currently down 7.
To Steve Bullock in the very red state of
Montana, Steve Bullock is the current governor
of Montana.
According to the new Montana State University
poll released yesterday, he is ahead by seven
against the incumbent Republican senator.
Now, if the name Steve Bullock sounds familiar,
it should not just because he's the current
governor, but he also was not not particularly
successful.
But he was in the 2020 Democratic primary
race for a little while and even was in at
least one debate.
I don't remember now exactly how many debates,
but he was at least one debate.
I think we've been talking about the Senate
balance in 2020.
And Democrats need to have a net gain of three
seats plus the presidency or a net gain of
four seats.
If Trump gets reelected to take control of
the Senate.
Now, why?
What does that mean?
Why does that matter whether Trump wins or
loses?
If you have a Senate that's 50/50, the tiebreaker
is the vise president.
Of course, if the tiebreaker is Mike Pence,
that doesn't go Democrats way.
So if Trump were to get reelected, Democrats
would need to get to 51 seats.
If Biden wins, they only need to get to 50.
So we're assuming and I believe that it's
a fair assumption that Democrats are going
to lose the Doug Jones seat in Alabama.
That's the special election seat.
It used to be Jeff Sessions, Senate seat.
Jeff Sessions was made Donald Trump's beleaguered
attorney general.
So that seat was up for special election.
Doug Jones won against the Republican nominee
who was serial accused sex assaulter Roy Moore.
Now, Jeff Sessions is trying to win his old
seat back and he's winning very, very handily
in the polling in Alabama.
So there's every indication Democrats are
going to lose that seat in Alabama.
So to net three, you've got to find four wins.
To net four, you've got to find five wins
because you're gonna lose that one seat.
So what are we looking at?
Arizona we've talked about Arizona before,
Mark Kelly, against the incumbent Republican,
Martha McSally.
She is in the seat previously held by John
McCain, the late John McCain.
She's not won any election.
She was appointed there, Maine.
Sarah Gideon is doing well against longtime
incumbent Senator Susan Collins, a Republican
who's often disappointed with Trump, but eventually
sides with him in Colorado.
Cory Gardner is not doing particularly well
in North Carolina.
Thom Tillis could lose, which would be great.
But now, with the addition of Montana, this
adds a new element.
Now, a few caveats on the seven point lead
that Steve Bullock has in Montana.
Number one, it's forty six to thirty nine.
So it's a seven point lead, but forty six
plus thirty nine is only eighty five.
That leaves fifteen up in the air.
And sometimes that breaks for the incumbent.
So that's one caveat.
One of the reasons that Bullock is doing well
in Montana is that as the current governor,
as I told you, he's done really well with
Corona virus.
He has a 70 percent approval on his handling
of Corona virus, only a 48 percent approval
for the incumbent Senator Steve Daines.
In terms of his handling of Corona virus,
of course, governors and senators have different
roles in the context of Corona virus.
2020 could quickly become Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell's worst nightmare if
some of these races go the Democrats way.
But it's up to us to make it so.
We need to get out and vote and not assume
any single race in any state.
Now, I have other outrageous news for Montana
as well.
There is a hypothetical presidential polling
being done.
I guess at this point it's not really hypothetical
in the sense that Joe Biden's the only candidate
left.
Trump is only ahead by five in the presidential
polling against Joe Biden in Montana.
Remember, in 2016, Trump beat Hillary by 20
in Montana.
Now, admittedly, libertarian Gary Johnson
got 5.
Points in Montana in 2016.
So maybe that these numbers need to be adjusted
for that, but this is a big swing.
Call it a ten point swing.
Call it a 15 point swing.
If indeed Donald Trump only wins Montana by
five, it would be a very bad November for
Donald Trump.
Does it pass the sniff test that Trump is
only up five in Montana?
I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
These are early numbers.
Anyway, we shouldn't be assuming anything.
There's much to work for.
But the Senate, which a year ago I would look
two years ago, I was saying Democrats don't
really have a chance in November of twenty
twenty for the Senate.
One year ago I was saying it's possible, but
it's a big uphill battle.
Six months ago, I was saying it's possible.
Now, this is a real possibility.
I don't I don't think it's likely.
I think.
I still think if I had a bet, I would say
you got to give me odds to bet on Democrats
in taking the Senate.
But there is now a very clear path and it
is not a wholly unrealistic path.
Democrats would need a couple of these races
to go against the incumbent in the end.
That can be tough, but a lot of good races
to get involved in and really great numbers
out of Montana.
We'll keep following it.